[Music]
animated movies are the best they're
full of beautiful art amazing color cute
characters and catchy music let's take a
look at some of the best original songs
to be featured in animated movies some
of them are totally unforgettable if
this is your first time at the things
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up now let's check out the 18 best
original songs from animated movies you
can't forget Pharrell Williams happy
Despicable Me has got to be one of the
most fun movies of all time supervillain
GRU is a hilarious bad guy when he finds
himself a single dad to three precocious
little girls he becomes truly charming
and who can resist those minions the
sequel was even cuter GRU is a
full-blown dad and thriving in the role
one of the best things to come out of
Despicable Me 2 is its catchy soundtrack
one song in particular has been stuck in
our collective heads ever since happy by
Pharrell Williams is the toe-tapping ear
candy that makes the second film a
treasure the song is so bright it can't
help but make you well happy
[Music]
imagine dragons zero Ralph breaks the
Internet is the upcoming sequel to the
awesome record Ralph in the movie Ralph
and vanellope find a Wi-Fi router they
go on a fun-filled adventure together in
through the internet the movie features
an original song from the band imagine
dragons the band must have had a great
time making the song they made a
fantastic music video honoring the movie
with its retro arcade theme the band
loved the movie so much they even made a
cameo in it Disney fans were already
psyched for the sequel but now music
lovers are on board too the movie has a
ton of fun cameos in it video game
characters and Disney Princesses show up
to add to the story post Malone and
swallow sunflower there's a big animated
film coming out this December spider-man
into the spider verse is an epic story
about the web slinging hero he travels
through parallel dimensions to team up
with other spider-man together they team
up to stop the destruction of all
reality the movie features an original
track by huge artists posts Malone the
track also features the talented sois
Lee it's sure to be as big of a hit as
the movie post since wah wrote the song
together just for the film they made a
video for it too
it features tons of sneak peeks into the
movie if the video is any hint the
movies will be epic it has such a cool
visual style
it features nods to spider-man's
comic-book origins
mashed up with modern CGI effects Justin
Timberlake can't stop the feeling when
it comes to animated movies that feature
great music trolls is at the top of the
list
this fun-filled rainbow romp is full of
fantastic songs the movie is like a
non-stop colorful concert the talented
voice actors who bring the trolls to
life cover a huge catalogue of songs
it's not an easy task to both play a
character and cover a famous song to the
Charles sing hits from acts like Simon &
Garfunkel and Lionel Richie it's not all
big pop covers there are original tracks
to Justin Timberlake helped write can't
stop the feeling for the
[Music]
the song was a huge success and was
nominated for several awards Randy
Newman you've got a friend in me the Toy
Story films are some of the biggest in
animated film history
the friendship between Buzz and Woody is
a classic pairing their relationship was
a central part of all four movies the
pair of polar opposites match up to
create one of the best on-screen
friendships ever the movie wasn't just
made into a hit with awesome friendships
alone the incredible music is also one
of the most memorable parts of these
amazing films most of the soundtracks
are original one of the biggest hits to
come out of the whole franchise is
you've got a friend in me the song was
written and performed by Randy Newman
Tegan and Sara feats the Lonely Island's
everything is awesome the lego movie was
a total hit it's an epic story and
awesome characters made it an instant
classic you can't help but love the fun
characters and amazing music the movie
is even famous for its catchy original
song everything is awesome is featured
in the film over and over it's even a
reference to the major themes and plot
of the movie the song was written by a
team including the Lonely Island the
band performed the catchy number with
Tegan and Sara on the soundtrack
Counting Crows accidentally in love
Counting Crows have been an award
winning bands for decades they've been
on international tours and released 11
albums they're no stranger to big hits
their original song accidentally in love
added their signature semi bluegrass
sound to the film Shrek 2 this swampy
sequel is the next chapter in the
popular Shrek series accidentally in
love was a top 40 hit it was even
nominated for an Academy Award the song
was definitely part of the movie's
success this uplifting song is about the
beauty of unexpected love Billy Crystal
John Goodman if I didn't have you an
original song on a soundtrack makes any
movie even more awesome having one
performed by two of the stars is even
better Monsters Inc is the feel-good
story of two best friends they live
together they work together and they get
into trouble together on a soundtrack
they even seemed together the classic
Disney hit was written by Randy Newman
he's a pretty prolific Disney songwriter
he's been the talents behind several
huge smash hits John Goodman and Billy
Crystal are world-class actors hearing
them seeing as cartoon Monsters is a
huge treat it's great that they don't
take themselves too seriously the song
is fun upbeat and full of genuine
emotion sia rainbow My Little Pony the
movie was the feature-length story fans
how to waited for the movie follows the
main six as they embark on a quest to
save Canterlot they have to leave the
security of Equestria for the first time
ever the friends leave their homeland
behind in order to save it they meet
lots of new people and friends on their
epic quest they're up against a
mysterious dark force and they have the
power of their friendship on their side
see it performed the soundtrack hit
rainbow
[Applause]
the song is super catchy and full of
emotion in the video SIA is transformed
into her own pony the video proves how
much fun she had working on the project
her pony self hits the stage with a
bunch of hoofed backup dancers
Sheryl Crow real gone cars was one of
the most memorable animated films of all
time fans loved the movie and its
characters the movies marches everywhere
- you can't go anywhere that's kids
without seeing at least one pair of cars
shoes the movie has a really fun
soundtrack megastar Sheryl Crow co-wrote
and performs the original song real gone
for the film soundtrack the hit has her
signature of rock sound with fun
electric guitar riffs and sassy lyrics
the song is really catchy it's upbeat
sound is the perfect match for the
movies fun fill the song hit the top 150
Armony can you see the star is an
awesome holiday movie the story focuses
on a brave little donkey and his animal
friends they become the unlikely heroes
of the very first Christmas the whole
movie is adorable and full of fun music
fifth harmony contributed their song can
you see to the heartwarming tale the
song is full of holiday emotion it's a
touching version of the story of the
Christmas star you don't have to be
religious to appreciate the moving
emotion behind the song or its story
other huge stars like Mariah Carey and
pentatonix contributed songs as well
this touching family classic is sure to
get you in the holiday spirit Verdi
Mumford & Sons learn me right
brave is one of the best animated films
of our time it features the first Disney
Princess who doesn't want to get married
that's pretty awesome Merida is a tough
and fierce princess all on her own and
doesn't need a prince to take care of
her this movie focuses on something so
much more important than romantic love
the story is all about the love between
family the song learn me right ran under
the closing credits of the film it was
the perfect finale to an emotional and
heartwarming story about love courage
and forgiveness the song was written
produced and arranged by the
award-winning bands missions they'll
soon discover this
Bob Squarepants movie maybe one of the
most talked-about animated features ever
the show ran for so long and was so
beloved that fans were going crazy about
the movie
no one could wait for its release once
it was out it seems like everyone was
storming the theaters to see it the
movie carried on the shows fun tone the
soundtrack included a lot of beloved
songs from fantastic artists as well as
a killer original track The Shins are a
successful bands with a unique sound
they've been featured in soundtracks for
films like Garden State they contributed
the song they'll soon discover to the
movie's original soundtrack Grace Potter
something that I want tangled is the
charming Disney adaption of the classic
tale Rapunzel the movie is about a
princess with magical powers who is
kidnapped and held in a tower
one day she meets the ruggish Flynn who
shows her the outside world with his
help she discovers who her real family
is and returns to life as a royal they
also fall in love which is pretty cute
many songs on the soundtrack are
performs by Mandy Moore Mandy lends her
voice to the plucky Rapunzel one song
that wasn't sung by Mandy is something I
want by Grace Porter this upbeat song is
the perfect music to accompany the
credits of the film
[Music]
Skrillex bug hunt Noisia remix you've
probably heard of Skrillex before he's
insanely popular EDM artists who's
toured the world on his own as well as
festivals it might surprise you that he
contributed to a children's film when it
comes to kids movies wreckit-ralph is
pretty awesome
people of all ages can't resist this
hilarious story about video game
characters and their world
the song is an intense masterpiece that
helps the movie develop its otherworldly
feel the track is epic at over 7 minutes
long it's a bold choice for an animated
film and it rocks Ralph and vanellope
wild adventures wouldn't be half as
exciting without the carefully chosen
soundtrack plane under them every movie
needs music to build suspense show
emotion and tell a story
Landon pig Lucie Schwartz darling I do
Landon Pig and Lucie Schwartz co-wrote
and performed this romantic song for the
Shrek Forever After soundtrack the movie
is a little dark for an animated feature
shrek is facing a midlife crisis he's
emotionally vulnerable Rumpelstiltskin
is able to convince him to let himself
be erased from existence he's trapped in
a dark alternate universe where
Rumpelstiltskin is still in charge the
movie is definitely full of sadness and
dark emotion but the love and shark's
heart is still there this song perfectly
captures the mood of the movie it's sad
and brooding but also romantic and sweet
it would be an epic breakup song
[Applause]
this track on the soundtrack may just be
the most emotional Camille loofah stone
ratatouille is an incredibly fun movie
about friendship and food it's the story
of a rat who wants more for himself he's
not happy eating garbage and living in
the sewers of Paris no he has big dreams
he wants to be a five-star chef he
befriends a struggling human cook and
together the pair makes culinary history
the movie is warm happy inspiring and
charming the song loofa song by Camille
is a perfect accompaniment to the story
it's delicate and jaunty melody paired
with its sweet French lyrics make it the
secret sauce that brings up a flavor of
the film Don Felder heavy metal taking a
ride
heavy metal was one of the most iconic
animated features of all time
not only was it the first real taste of
anime for many Americans but it was also
one of the first animated features
intended for an older audience the movie
is set in a dark fantasy world ripped
right from the album covers of metal
bands one original track from the film
heavy metal taking a ride is a perfect
distillation of the genre the film
honors and has sick guitar riffs a heavy
bassline and epic imagery it serves as a
theme to this animated classic we hope
you enjoy - checking out these memorable
songs from animated movies we'll see you
next time
[Music]